peut-être un jour open [ __ ] les
cathédrales telle qu'elle l'était au
moyen-âge en attendant cette éventuelle
restauration la cathédrale d'amiens par
un jeu de lumières retrouve ses couleurs
passées il s'agit d'une première
mondiale un tour de force sur le plan
technique qu'il faut voir très vite car
la reconstitution ne dure que jusqu'au 2
janvier 2000 gérard dalmaz et michel
levasseur se sont laissés séduire la
lune écarte le rideau de la nuit en
coulisses elle assiste au miracle damien
la plus belle cathédrale gothique du
monde retrouvent pour quelques jours
seulement les atours de sa jeunesse du
xiiie siècle
l'art coloration parfaite des trois
portes un mille sculpture première
mondiale dimension précision
au moyen âge cette bande dessinée de
pierre sanctifié étaient peintes de
couleurs vives mises en valeur par les
lampes à huile d'un lustre dans chaque
portable pas facile de restituer cet
effet théâtral et pourtant il est là
grâce à la photographie puis à
l'informatique
ce qu'on appelle c'est qu'on a fait des
prises de vue en simulant l'éclairage et
enr projette non seulement de la lumière
mais des ombres modeler pour donner un
relief sur les sculptures comme si la
nuit revenait de l'intérieur des
portails c'est un trompe l'oeil
six projecteurs si grande diapos d'une
précision diabolique
et c'est l'apparition de la vie les
couleurs font oublier des siècles de
pluies s'étendent recherches pour
retrouver scientifiquement les bons
pigments sur les bons personnages
travail de titan orchestrée par la
municipalité amiénoise
ce qui surprend ce sont les couleurs
éclatantes est ce bien normal
normal au xiiie siècle on a une notion
des contrastes qui n'est plus celle de
l'homme d'aujourd'hui donc l'évolution
des goûts l'évolution des temps a fait
que nous avons perdu ce sens des
contrastes on les retrouve aujourd'hui
ian
jadis egypte grèce rome les sanctuaires
était peint la chrétienté a fait la même
chose pour mieux toucher la foi du
croyant lui 100 ans après nos montres
heures de rêve obtiennent la beauté
spirituelle la cathédrale d'amiens
semble toucher le ciel